[Music]  I'm a debride I'm a reporter now I  always seem to find myself questioning  something the government may not be  looking at I found something really bad  look around in the world who do you see  a planet on the brink of collapse in the  games are disposable like bad and soon  be combined this is a new race your  species the higher life-form  what do you want me out  we cannot just hurt people  study  we have a deal I create so many snacks  to that power it's not completely awful  you have no idea how much you're scaring  me right now a walk away  and you just might survive guys you do  not want to do this trust me  we'll always come at a cost  [Music]  going down the street oh I have a  parasite yeah name is Chen  [Music]